um you're you're reviewing this book
i i don't know if reviewing is the
proper word um
you don't you're not really reviewing
you're not really critiquing you're
breaking it down for people you're
deconstructing the dialogue quite
literally
and i was not overly familiar with this
book which is embarrassing as a
scientist i suppose my scientist
credentials get taken away
for saying that um and so in the past
few days i've really been digging deep
and i've been listening to all your
your talks about it and so i want to
start there because
this book seems to be realistically the
epitome of everything
i'm interested in in science i love
science i love pulsars i love black
holes i love that sm
but i also love communicating with
people
talking to people about it and also
understanding why scientists think and
do the things they do
that book is the epitome epitome of all
that so so i want to pass that off to
you
why is this book important to you what
made you start delving into this book
again
in your life yeah this is an excellent
question of course you know it's one of
the most
uh well trodden tales in all of science
that galileo was tortured
imprisoned uh you know hung by the rack
or his thumbs or whatever they used to
do back then
literally getting medieval on him or
post-medieval
uh and it was all for writing this book
right you know this this poor
scientist who was tortured uh merely for
espousing beliefs that went counter to
the imperialist
you know uh patriarchy at the time and
it turns out nothing could be further
from the truth
and in fact uh reading it again as an
adult after having
tried to get through it as a younger
person but not making it all the way
through
but really buckling down to make it all
the way through this time revealed to me
more than ever why galileo is my hero
and why he will always be my hero
because he
had he had it all he had everything that
i aspire to
and more his intellect
was razor sharp he was deferent but he
was egotistical
he was uh he was humble and yet he was
incredibly impolitic and impertinent
there are all too many of his human
foibles that go into it
and you really can't get a sense of it
merely by
you know reading the treatments of his
work by other people
and the hagiography of him which in some
ways is aptly put
is uh is sort of a disservice to getting
to know him
as a human being which actually made him
much more
impressive to me now especially as a
mature scientist
but but i think for all scientists and
what really was the obstacle brennan
which is so
you know kind of foolish and childish is
that i couldn't find
this book on audiobook and i'm like you
know this book is printed on you know
this this
this gauzy paper and it's uh 587 pages
long
and i don't know about you but i haven't
read that many books like that since i
became a scientist
that are this long that aren't textbooks
and even the textbook jackson's behind
me you know you plowed through that
yes of course that might be 700 pages
but you don't read the whole book it's
not like a novel or something like that
this is unput down-able and in a sense
but uh but i
also the way that i consume information
and and you might be similar as a
podcaster extraordinaire well
by the way you're one of the people that
really inspired me to up my game
and to get great guests and to go deep
as a human being
uh in particular your interview with ray
weiss is is a legacy
interview uh that really inspired me to
do an interview with him and so i want
to thank you for that
and um i won't tell you that you know
what what he said about me at the end
although you might have watched it
uh he thought i was pretty good so uh
that's the highest in communion one can
get
but anyway like you i'm sure we consume
things
as we produce things namely orally a you
orally and we speak a lot orally over
and so i look for the audiobook version
of it and found it
not then i look for the uh the kindle
version of it so i can
read in bed you know this thing is heavy
uh and
uh and i couldn't find it and in a sense
i'm glad i couldn't because
i end up taking you know literally
thousands of notes on this
but it inspired me to do something which
is to create the first audio book ever
made of any of galileo's works and the
hope is with help from
my listeners who have reached out to me
and and maybe even you'll get interested
in this we're going to translate all of
galileo's books none of which are
quite as long as this one as long as one
of all of his books
and some say the most important we're
going to translate that make audio books
make kindled versions of it
and in so doing we're going to bring it
to a completely different audience
perhaps an illustrated version of it as
well perhaps a course you know we sit
around we talk about it
because i think these are the kind of
conversations that made me want to be a
scientist in the first place
and if you i know you're like me because
you as i said you inspire me to do
new things on my podcast and everyone
should subscribe i'm going to post on my
channel
so immediately subscribe to brandon's
stay to the universe
uh channel uh itunes leave a review for
him
as i have uh just a phenomenal superstar
rising star
although you're pretty high up you're
not reaching your apogee yet but you're
getting there
yes i appreciate that bri hopefully by
the way you call me in a podcast
extraordinaire
here i'm using the wrong microphone in
the intro so hopefully it sounds a tiny
bit better now does it
well yeah it sounds fine we all we all
make you know uh
we all make some limitations in our
inner knowledge yeah of course
yeah now i will say like um i have like
branded my skull with ray weiss and what
he said to me after the interview too
because he was a very very kind he's
like spent a couple minutes
going over how good of a job he think
and you could just tell he's so
like nurturing as a as an advisor as a
professor as
someone who oversees uh young
researchers he is
unlike many people in this field that i
have met
in the way that he recognizes i'm
reading this book right now complete
aside about leadership and one of the
great
things about leadership is
the leader needs to be able to take
people aside and positively and
reinforce them and you can tell that ray
weiss has like built that into his uh
his spirit so i appreciate that i'm it's
excellent that i
uh that i motivated you um i wish you
would have motivated me during
the pandemic because you were on fire
during the pandemic
and i was the opposite you know like
every other day i was like i think i
averaged like maybe one episode every
three weeks during the panda because it
was ju
i just i don't know sitting in the house
is just not
not great but back to the the galileo
i think it would be fantastic to do a
series where
we um not we maybe you actually
really do the audiobook uh sort of
um chapter by chapter and then the end
of the chapter or even interspersed
throughout the chapters
we break to a group of scientists
who uh i'd be happy to partake or you
know if you want to get other people
that's whatever
and then we discuss it sort of break it
down the
actual scientific underlying aspects of
it and also the societal aspects so
things like confirmation bias are so
prevalent in this work things
um like how you take two seemingly
obvious observations in the universe and
make it such that you know one of them
has to be wrong you have to be uh
biased in seeing that some way um for
example
two two objects falling at the same
speed even though the different masses
um that's not a real phenomenon right
or rather that is a real phenomenon
forgive me
but people in galileo's day
might have not known very much about air
resistance and so may have literally
been tricked into
believing that objects with different
masses
do not fall at the same you know you
drop a feather and a penny
on the moon you might have a different
result than if you drop them in
california
for example and so no this is all
incredibly important information and i'd
be happy to collaborate with you on this
i think we could find
an excellent panel of physicists science
communicators from all across the realm
if you will and and come up with
something really cool i think we could
absolutely come up with something so
yeah count me in man count me
awesome yeah i mean i found that you
know it's it's interesting because you
get
all sorts of reactions i should say that
the thing that prompted me to reread
this book
was really this appearance that i made
on a uh on the book club which is a
production of prager university
which is definitely a you know right
right of the
of the center uh outlet for for
information for short videos and so
forth you know almost three million
subscribers and gets about almost 2
billion views a year i'd already made a
a prager university video entitled uh
what's a bigger leap of faith
god or the multiverse that received
about 5 million views
so far on different platforms and um and
with that you know there's there's a lot
of kind of
uh attention that comes my way from
doing such videos
the one i did recently was about the
galileo's dialogue on two chief world
systems
and that's kind of an unusual thing you
know people think of oh he's just a
right winger but he's actually
incredibly interested
in all different branches of of culture
and the point that i wanted to make is
that this is a book of culture this is
not just merely a science book
and so as such it could be discussed
with anybody and actually it's turned
out to be one of their most
popular videos in this genre receiving
in
in under a week over 1.1 million views
of a 30-minute video
uh dialogue between me and michael
knowles who's another conservative
pundit and has become a friend uh and
and
this topic of you know of whether or not
we can have a dialogue first of all
what does it mean to have a dialogue
what does it mean to be a scientist and
have scientific dialogues
and it's just funny to to see uh
colleagues and friends
quote unquote twitter friends i mean you
and i have never met in real life but we
will someday i'm confident of it because
i want to
but there are people on twitter i could
care less about and oh you really on
prager university you know it's oh
here's here's something yeah
i was going to ask you that exact thing
yeah yeah so yeah we could definitely
talk about that but but it's just funny
because they never watch it they just
they just commented on oh it's supported
by oil billionaires which is not not
correct
factually yeah um but uh but of course
you believe everything on wikipedia
because it's you know the source of all
knowledge is the easiest lowest hanging
fruit that someone can consume
so yeah you know i've lost friends over
these things but uh you know i kind of
view it as a filter
as a filter of filtering out people that
aren't really worth you know having in
my virtual life and so for that sense
it's good but also it's a list
illustrative because it sees it reveals
all the biases that my so-called
scientific friends have
and even lay people that you should
trust you know science and that science
is monolithic and scientists you know
listen to evidence that i'd rather
have you know answers you know that uh
questions that cannot be answered than
answers that cannot be questioned
like you religious nuts like um some
sort of zealot anyway
these all kind of um you know conspired
to me to be
really kind of delicious and and the
icing on the cake is that
you know this month this quarter's been
really prolific for me in terms of
output
in that i'm featured in this you know
traditional values kind of conservative
um you know outlet namely prager
university which is you know has a pro
uh theistic monotheistic slant ethical
modernism
and then i'm featured on the cover of uh
skeptic magazine
which is a far you know different type
of venue and it all involves these types
of biases that scientists are
susceptible to
just like every other person out there
yeah no i
i think that's excellent and i don't
think that any scientist should ever
think like what are the values of the
the people that i'm presenting to
so i'm assuming they're not insane you
know i'm not talking about don't go talk
to
literal nazis maybe or do i mean or do
um because today you could use an
education too um but
but you get my point it's like that is a
weird thing to me and i struggle with
that a lot for the position i'm in
because
you are uh this is true of academics i'm
i guess scared of the cancellation that
might come
and i'm not scared neces scared
necessarily i'm not like i don't
my heart rate and my heart's not racing
i don't think i'm gonna be but you know
i realize that
that's a very real phenomenon now and so
you are in a situation where you can
maybe collaborate with prageru or
something like that
but oftentimes i feel a little
apprehensive about doing that or posting
certain things on twitter because
i'm not in a situation yet where i am i
guess you'd say
financially like truly financially
independent
the show makes money that sort of thing
but but um i
really do feel like politics is becoming
an important aspect of making a career
in academics and
and i do see a lot of that like
apprehension to do stuff like prageru
and it makes no sense to me
because the entire point of me forming
the state of the universe was that if
you look
at where um science denialism and i
don't really like that term anymore
because it's been
politicized and weaponized and that's
not the way i mean it but
people who generally are not interested
in science is what i mean
you find those people in very rural
areas at least i do and those are the
areas i grew up in
and so i started the state of the
universe with the goal of reaching those
people and talking to those people
and if the only platforms you're willing
to talk to
are far left like podcasty platforms
about science
you're not reaching anyone that isn't
already interested in the subject matter
which defeats the entire purpose of even
talking about the science
you might as well just not even have a
speech just don't talk
you just don't do the outreach so i
think we're very
similar in that mindset and um yeah so i
i do i mean you should you know i'm not
gonna advise you that you should you
know
uh just like torpedo your whole you know
career whatever connections you make
by the way you know i always say my
podcast isn't political or it's
politically neutral and that's because
i'll have people like ben shapiro
uh dennis prager michael knowles on and
i'll have you know eric weinstein here's
noam chomsky
he's on the podcast for our second
appearance coming up hopefully soon
um and you know i have these people i i
don't talk about their political views
on which i find
you know odious and and um and unserious
and not worthy of of uh
you know discussion but i am fully
interested and i you know
i'll i'll defy anybody who says i can't
talk to somebody
and this is the whole notion of
cancellation and and
book burning and so forth that's really
kind of medieval
getting on top except now it's coming
mostly from the other side you know it
used to be the mccarthyists were
were kind of burning books on the right
and i had on you know dave rubin
and you know people like him and other
people you know who saying their books
are being banned and canceled and
and their book deals are getting
canceled left and right and
you know how unscientific is that how
ignorant is that to
cancel someone because of ideas yes
someone's actively advocating to do
public harm i would never have such a
person on
um i find that morally reprehensible i
wouldn't use that
but on the other hand you know i'm not
if people have criticized
almost any kind of thing that you can
imagine that i've had on they just
disagree with it or they'll
you know put up some some trolling
comments
but um but i've learned to like defy
that you know
notion of not reading uh comments
because i think it gives it
bolsters if you will maybe i'm subject
to my own confirmation bias
but it bolsters the idea that people
that actually care
and are willing to change your opinion
you know my litmus test is if i debate
you brandon and you're going to convince
me of your radical right-wing ideology
to follow the guy with the horns
uh to to glory and victory i i will
listen to you
if and only if i feel like you can
change my mind and if i am honest i have
to do an inventory
um on my soul in judaism it's called you
know counting of the soul
am i really going to change my mind
listening to to them
uh to brandon or listening to ben
shapiro listening to nom chomsky
and if not i'm not going to debate those
those sorts of issues you know they're
not going to convince me to convert to
you know scientology it's just not going
to happen
but you know if they want to talk about
scientists that's something i'm willing
to listen to
and not all you know kind of critiques
are equally valid
but you know once you get above this
certain threshold they call it the
overton window you know where it's like
how impermissible on the left is your
opinion to somebody who's on the right
for example and vice versa yeah but i
find you know the only kind of
polarization i'm interested in is of the
cosmic microwave background
and not necessarily about politics left
or right so i try to have an equal
balance half and half
but even so i'm finding it very
illustrative to do
what makes me feel good so i always say
you know like my
my days are spent far more often on
telecons
than telescopes and that's exactly the
opposite of what i thought being an
astronomer would be like
and so a lot of times i have to talk to
people you know at different agencies
and organizations
and logistics and and stuff it's not all
looking through at my non-existent
stubble and stroking it and looking up
at the heavens it's very mundane you
know it's looking yeah
well is this concrete and this water
chiller gonna get paid on this invoice
or are they gonna stop
deliveries and it's it's very mundane i
have to do it
i have to do it i don't want to do it i
have to do it it's just like exercise i
have to do it and sometimes i don't want
to do it
but when i talk to people like you it's
because i want to talk to people like
you
and that's kind of been my fuel in the
past nine months of what i call pandemic
podcasting
and so i look at and i say do i want to
talk to brynn yeah hell yes if it's a
hell yes i'll do it
yeah no i i i think that's that's
and i think that's sometimes why i get
tired of podcasting it because i
i do kind of you know make sure that
certain guests check certain boxes and
and it can make it not fun you know if
uh
if you're only talking to people with a
very rigid set of ideas sometimes it
cannot be fun
and uh i that's just
i guess so maybe i should take a note
out of your book and uh
and and branch out and try to get some
some different look at it like it's an
experiment you know looking
like you're doing an experiment and some
experiments fail most experiments fail
take it from me
of course yeah and um and just do you
know do 100 episodes do 100 podcasts do
you know find the people do branch out
of just pure science
branch out of cosmology i know i know
the weird part about that is though
the name of the the show right the state
of the universe so it's like
it's a damn astronomy show what am i
gonna do i thought about
literally making a second show which was
no different than the first show
but it's called the state of the
multiverse and the in that show i would
talk to people outside of astronomy and
physics
um but even that might be a little too
i don't know well i don't wanna you know
make make pronouncements as if i'm an
expert i've grown
really rapidly putting game stock share
price to shame
uh but uh but i treasure all my list
it's actually you know what i found is
is half the work is making the
the episodes but really if you don't do
the other half which is marketing and
promoting them
uh it's really almost like you're not
you're not gonna get anything done it's
the case yes
you need a hundred percent of the of the
uh
vectors to be pointing in the same
direction and if you don't
you know you'll get some traction and
you'll get some feedback and view and
maybe you don't care maybe you don't
want advertisers and you know that
that's a sure way to turn
a hobby into a hassle but nevertheless
um you know we all have realities we
have to make ends meet and we have to
um make an accounting of our of our
material
souls as well as our as our other
worldly heavenly souls
and so i'll keep doing stuff yeah if you
want to talk it doesn't matter what your
pocket nobody's gonna say oh well you
know what brandon your podcast called
state of the universe which
definitely means that you're talking
about cosmology uh just as brian
keating's you know is about into the
impossible
which is who knows what the heck that
means uh but but nevertheless you cannot
break out of it and have noam chomsky on
or or whatever no no not at all in fact
what i like about it is then i found
this to be true
i had on um david curtly who's the
proprietor of the geeks guide to the
galaxy podcast one of my favorite
podcasts
he was on my show i was on his show
earlier last year late last year rather
and um yeah he has on everyone paul
krugman
to me and sean carroll to uh you know he
you know he's just an amazing guy but
one thing he he tries to weave through
is he
he loves to geek out on science fiction
that's his that's his bread and butter
but he uses that
as a delivery vector to get into
conversations with people
like paul krugman that he might not ever
have access to
yeah so the lesson you're telling me
brian in so many words is i need to stop
being a [ __ ] and i will do that okay
i will do that well maybe that's not
we're not allowed to say that i don't
know
i don't know what's allowed to be said
anymore brian but don't worry let's um
let's relate your experience do you hear
this construction outside i hope it's
not
too loud i hope you can't hear it um
good so let's relate this book to your
real life experiences so i have losing
the nobel prize
right here yeah i was flipping through
it again i read i think i read it twice
now fully it's a it's a fantastic book
can't recommend it enough
um and you sent me a couple copies that
i've given away to listeners on the
patreon so there's a plug if you want to
be on the patreon
um so let's relate that experience
because
in in the book um on two chief world
systems
it's a describe the book quickly it's
galileo
coming up with this dialogue where you
pit geocentrism against heliocentrism
is that right yeah yeah exactly he calls
it you know ptolemaic or peripatetic
but it's exactly right it's you know
it's a threefold dialogue between
three of galileo's bffs there's galileo
here's uh segredo and here's simplicio
of course galileo is not called
galileo in the book he's not that
arrogant to do something i would do but
he calls
uh the character that best represents
his perspective literally and physically
uh called salviati which kind of means
like the savior
the saving one and then simplicio is
like the [ __ ]
uh simplicio is like the simpleton and
he puts this three-part
dialogue which is uh which is very
unusual nowadays
but back then was a little bit more
common and he actually used this format
twice in his writing career he wrote
like 15 or 20 books
and i intend to go through and make
audio versions of them all
uh sort of my contribution my my my work
oh my
what do you call that my um beatitudes
or whatever towards the saint
galileo so yes so it's a dialogue in
three over four days
and each day they discuss different
aspects that are foreign against
aristotelian
or ptolemaic or geocentric cosmology
arguments for it and against it and um
and in the end i'm not going to spoil
how it actually ends
but it's it's not at all clear that uh
the
arguments put forth by the brilliant
otherwise brilliant galileo
actually are dispositive in any way
towards what the
what the resolution that we now know to
be the case is the sun
is not going around the earth but it is
uh essentially the other way around
although not exactly it doesn't exactly
go
around the sun but that's a that's a
side note
yes yeah so you talk about this book as
being sort of
the epitome of of popular science books
yes um you're you're a big fan of the
way that the scientific method is broken
down
in almost a again a dialogue
as opposed to a bullet point or a rigid
set
of of ways in which you should go about
science and
that is a great telling of the human
side of science because in the human
side of science
there is no like you you don't walk into
my lab at rit
and and see like okay we have to make a
hypothesis
okay after the hypothesis is made we
have to uh you know do
make observations and test blah blah
blah we there's no
checklist that's what i do that's as
soon as i put on the lab coat first
though you forgot that
yes of course in the goggles and a mask
you better have your mask on
um and so that's not how science works
in fact i often talk about on this show
the fact that
the scientific method is is kind of
not even a a real thing in the truest
sense of the
from the top down it's real from the top
down there's a method of our madness
but if you look at the greatest
scientific
adventures and advent inventions of all
time what you find is that the ways in
which they were found
it it's generally not always a theory
was made
that that theorized a prediction could
be made and the prediction was
was true and then voila we have
something that's accepted by the
community
a lot of times this stuff happens very
happenstance very oddly very out of
order
you can look at the cmb for example
right the cmb is a great example
of there was a prediction made that
something like the cmb would exist
but the prediction was wrong right the
prediction was like 30 kelvin or
something like that
um and so the the and then the people
who actually found the cmb
weren't even looking for the cmb so it's
the cmb is a great example of the way
science has
no true methodology it has a forward
progress
but i think it struggles to have a
methodology and
that book covers that perfectly because
it's saying
here's all this information we have how
are we going to get a result out of
this wealth of information and the way
in which you get the result again
is a transitional period but in no way a
methodology and it really tells the
human side of science i feel
yeah yeah i'm actually doing another
video a third video for pregnant
university
and it's tentatively titled you know
scientist says don't trust scientists
because in reality the least likely
person to trust a scientist
is another scientist you tell me
something i don't say yeah i don't say
oh brett brennan told me you know he's
this brilliant guy he's at this
top-notch universe oh
yeah okay fine straight to publication
you know so i make the point that
scientists don't trust
it and don't trust other scientists and
that's not a bad thing because
part of the scientific method which you
are absolutely 100 correct about there
is no such thing as the scientific
method
instead it's an iterative process that
itself is still being
updated with a methodology and uh but
but generally
speaking it involves a couple of major
points and and those are
you know some sort of observation that
alerts somebody to a discrepancy between
understanding that had been reached
before by perhaps the scientific method
or maybe not
it's only about 400 years old and and
since that time you know bacon and
and people like galileo and then eben
and other people thousand years ago but
really to test the
hypothesis really requires
experimentation not just pure
speculation so that's what separates
the greeks the peripatetics from the uh
from the you know kind of galileos and
the bacons and so forth
and that they were actually doing
experimentation but even that
is not sufficient it's necessary but
it's not sufficient in the following
sense
because a scientist might do a test and
and say well that test you know can
actually confirm
an incorrect hypothesis let me give you
an example
i talked about this a little bit in
losing the nobel prize you know you look
at the sunset uh you know here in
california and the
sun goes down it gets kind of red well
the reason it gets red you might
correctly surmise is because there are
dust particles and aerosols in the
atmosphere
from forest fires and whatnot and
because of that
uh the the um the
scattering of blue light occurs more
readily and we get more red light
transmitted
well that's most consistent with a slab
approximation what's called the slab
approximation the atmosphere
is a flat slab layered on top of a flat
earth well
doesn't that prove that the uh earth is
a flat uh as a flat object yeah it's
much more
uh possible to confirm the flatness of
the earth and by the way you know
scientists are not now saying out there
that the earth is flat but
that hypothesis would be bolstered by
that observation here's another example
um michelson-morley experiment done at
my alma mater case western reserve
university
uh that showed that the earth is not
moving with respect to the ether
in a certain sense the earth is
stationary one might conclude in early
1900s scientists the earth is stationary
and is not moving and of course it is
but only under the incorrect hypothesis
of the uh of the ether being an active
force in the universe
so the point is that you cannot have one
simple definition of hypothesis
experiment or observation then in the
1900s a philosopher of science named
carl popper developed another kind of
augmentation to bolster
the scientific method as i just
described it and that involved uh
and that involved the op the opportunity
for a theory to be
falsified as a criterion for which you
should apprise its
its veracity as a scientific field and
there are problems with that
because in addition to the observation
and the experimental testing
and deductive and inductive reasoning
from the hypothesis
to the observations and so on there was
also consensus building
that you have to build a consensus well
guess what you know back then and peer
review et cetera so who
who are the peer reviewers for galileo
were they just stupid idiot
priests and and and popes who's a
freaking [ __ ] no
there were scientists to this day brenda
you know this there's a vatican
observatory that does amazing
work with a 3.6 meter class telescope uh
why would they have that if they're this
ignorami
and idiots they're not they're very
smart and they were smart back then so
guess what
there were scientists building a
peer-review case against galileo
using evidence that existed back then so
do you trust a scientist they were
scientists
aristotle was a scientist you know he
thought he was the first to discover
that whales
were mammals not fish he was the first
to come up the laws of logic that we
teach to our children you know in high
school to this very day
he also thought there were four elements
and that the
earth went was the center of the
universe because it was the heaviest
natural
place for it to go so science is
provisional that doesn't mean
that if you think the earth is flat
you're just as smart as somebody
who thinks the earth is a perfect sphere
we know it's not a perfect sphere
right so there are distinctions and
refinements but it's always provisional
and that's a good thing and i think yeah
people should know that and that's
really the subject of my upcoming video
about you know we hear this all the time
trust a scientist let me ask you brendan
i'm going to turn the table since this
is partially an into the impossible
podcast we
flip the script and and put the guest on
on the line i'm going to ask you mike of
course my final three questions at the
end for my patreon subscribers only
uh no i don't really have much of a
patreon i have a patreon i don't get any
money from it except for my mom
who sends me bills uh but um
you know to be fair my mom's a
subscriber to my patreon too
so yeah mom club maybe your mom can
subscribe to my patreon
uh all right i don't think she's going
after that game stock fiasco
yeah i hope she uh she put all the
proceeds into amc
um let me ask you when people say trust
scientists or listen to scientists what
do you think they really mean
uh in today's world you're talking about
yeah you know joe biden or
somebody tells us i trust science yes so
mario cuomo
mario cuomo uh what's his name uh andrew
cuomo yeah yeah
governor so i i have a um
a very well developed answer to this and
it might take a while but my
uh sim like if i'm boiling it down i
think it's a it's
political malfeasance i think it's a
political ploy to say trust the science
i think um and i actually think it does
a huge disservice to science
because it implies that many of the the
uh
things that you are supposed to be
trusting um
are finalized in the view of scientists
and i think that that is wholesome
a wholesome lie um so when i think that
people say trust the science
i think it's the same as them saying
trust anything trust me you shouldn't
trust them
uh you shouldn't trust me you shouldn't
trust really anyone without a
a a well-rounded um
you know sense or sense of their history
and
if you know anything about the history
of science you know that science does
change
it does morph it does um now you should
trust
like you were saying you should trust
science as a as an iterative process you
should trust that
we are as a community trying to get the
right answer right
but you should not trust if i come up to
you like you were meant saying
and i say um here's some settled science
you should trust it i don't think that's
true
right and i think like there's a lot of
places where the sciences
is just outright not settled that people
are trying to convince you uh
it is settled you know one of the more
uh i guess um
what's the word uh egregious
yeah i guess egregious but like
egregious isn't
i guess egregious i don't want to call
it egregious because then i'll i'll get
murdered
um but is is the idea that biological
men and women are identical in every way
i mean this people will tell you trust
the science trust the science
it's patently absurd that you should
trust that science and the reason it's
patently absurd that you should trust
that science is because that science
is not settled science um they've
very they've they've in essence done
what people who deny climate change do
which is they've they've plucked a very
tiny subset of a field
and they're citing them as the field uh
and it is a an overwhelming lie
um and so yeah when you look at the
selectivity
of their reporting or you know is this
replicatable i mean can you tell
i mean i don't want to get too you know
super controversial but i will say
you know it is possible to look at a
genetics of a human being and determine
that it is a
you know has two x chromosomes versus
two y chromosomes that's a scientific
fact
it is not possible to look and see if
that person is black you know
african black american but it's not
possible to say there are no genetic
differences and that's why racism
in addition to being a mendacious evil
you know falsehood
is is anti-scientific so racism has no
basis
to say that but then to say as people do
often
that because um you know because of the
historic you know sexism and
discrimination
against marginalized groups we have to
make sure that you know people who have
uh yeah what's now called gender
dysphoria
um used to be called you know something
something else you know because of that
that we
we want to make sure that these people
are treated fair of course we all want
that we all want them to be treated
fairly yeah
but we shouldn't say that science is
used to do that and i
feel you know like when when you see
things like that
i don't know how seriously people will
take that i do see things that worry me
nowadays like we're gonna have a
computer science search
you know and and the people you know
it'll be studying
uh anti-black racism and you know that
that's the goal of
like no one ever hired me and said
you're gonna do cosmology research and i
don't even care that it's about
anti-black racism you know
i'm i'm a lifetime member of the
national society of black physicists
as an honorary member i speak at their
conventions i'm a huge donor
you know my personal whatever meager
personal scrimpings i have
uh to their to their annual meetings
and uh and i love it i'm an active
participant we start but
you know to say to say that i have to
study contribution let's just say of of
african americans to cosmology
i think you know even even even you know
i i would start to to question
why am i being hired you know is this
scientific are you interested in
computer science are you interested in
cosmology
are you interested in social science we
can debate if that's an actual
uh you know an actual branch of
legitimate science but but
to me this listen to scientists really
means obey scientists
and that's the thing i'm worried about
uh because if you look back through this
history of science
uh from uh you know from the middle ages
of actually
since the uh since the scientific method
that we just
you know kind of loosely sketched out uh
you come up with people
like uh like trophy melisenko you know
like
uh like you know who is the architect of
the of the uh
you know basic massive famine that
killed you know millions of people
in the ukraine and and so forth you find
people like fritz haber you know who's a
who is a jewish german scientist in the
1900s who came up with the
uh heber bosch process fritz haber that
enabled us to eat breakfast this morning
you know because it was responsible for
the fertilizer process that feeds
literally half the food half the earth
is fed by this process now he was a
scientist he won the nobel prize in
chemistry in 1918.
after developing advocating and
personally witnessing
the utilization of chemical gas warfare
that killed 50 000 or so allied troops
in the trenches
of of northern europe in 1915.
so he's a scientist and actually
ironically macabre
irony um many members of his own family
were killed
by the same nazi government that came to
power afterwards
that used the same chemical that his
company had invented as a pesticide
called zyklon b
and of course you can't hold him
responsible for that but you ask
well he's a scientist should we listen
there were three other nobel prize
winners that he recruited
to participate in these shock gas troops
that the uh that the german army put
together in
world war one to the contravention
of the 1908 league of nations treaty
prohibition
against their use which germany was a
signatory to
so i don't have any faith in scientist
wisdom
after all science means knowledge it
doesn't mean wisdom
right yeah i think that they're like i i
i
i'm very troubled as well by um
the the left the leftist party in
america and i don't know if this is
happening across the world
um of them owning science i think that's
very problematic because you have a
party that in the last
10 years has actively pus pushed uh
you know uh anti-gmo legislation has
actively pushed
anti uh nuclear energy legislation
and so you have a a party that
you shouldn't trust them when they say
trust us we're scientists
you shouldn't trust them you simply
shouldn't um and i'm not saying you
shouldn't trust them on every issue
i'm like a classical liberal i am uh
so i and i often i've recently
discovered this
i was listening to a podcast it was i
forget which podcast it was but i
recently discovered this phenomenon
where people get out of jail
and then sue their uh their public
defender do you know that this happens
um so so this hap they people will get
out of jail
and sue their public defender for giving
them a bad sentence as opposed to suing
the prosecutor
the reason why psychologically is that
they don't blame the prosecutor the
prosecutor was doing the job
their their job they blame the public
defender because the public defender
failed at their job
and i equate my feelings to the
political left saying
trust the science in that exact frame of
mind i
do not fault members of the right
for being anti-scientific in some of
their viewpoints which i think that on
some of their viewpoints i think they
are
um and i'm talking mainstream sort of
right-wingers
are anti-scientific and for some of
their views um
i don't blame them for that i i would
like to change their mind i would like
to talk to them i would like to discuss
it i would like to find out
where our differences arise but i don't
blame them for that
as much as i blame the left who is my
public defender
who's failed me who has convinced
society at large that they are the party
of science without actually being
scientific in a number of ways
so i feel a people on twitter often
think i'm like a right-wing nut because
of how much i criticize the left
i hate these people sometimes because
they're taking
um what i consider to be the party that
that should be standing up for people
that should be working
to spread science amongst the population
and they are discrediting it all
and it angers the watch they should be
the watchdog they were traditionally in
the
that's what i'm saying it's been
inverted wherein people had a notion
that the right the mccarthyites and so
forth and even my friend eric weinstein
who agrees very wholeheartedly with you
you know when i asked him well where's
the danger on the right he'll point to
this you know
cook and coakley thing of 1970 you know
it's like before i was born let alone
before you were born
and that's like the most recent thing on
the right and then on the left it's just
like he
he just goes off on them because like
you know for example he doesn't get
invited anymore he used to have friends
at the new york times they did a cover
piece on him
a couple years ago in this intellectual
dark web which is comprised almost
entirely of people on the left
you know sam harris him his brother
brett um
etc and um and slowly this became
he became persona non grata and that
perpetuated this cycle where now he
cannot get
invited on left-wing shows um msnbc
and new york times podcast etc npr they
won't call him they don't give him the
time of day
and so what's left if he wants to spread
a message which he views as valid
is he gets invitations from glenn beck
and ben shapiro and all
sorts of people that are certainly on
the right now what does that do well
that just gives intellectual fodder
for people on the left to say see you
only go on on
on these right-wing crackpots shows so
it's this perpetuating cycle of
again what is it confirmation bias and
so you know you and i were talking
before the show about
like is confirmation bias alive and well
i talk about a lot and losing the nobel
prize how it afflicted me personally
and i think it's it's having you know
one of the takeaways from my year of
pandemic podcasting and talking
to so many eminent people including
eight nobel prize winners
is uh is this notion of groupthink and
how powerful it is
and how how scientific stories might be
going untold
because they might violate a narrative
which is believed to be
preferable natural unique etc
and i actually you know it's funny
because even in my
uh in my non-political life my
scientific life i get
criticized for being too much in the
inflation camp or too much in the
in the opposition to inflation which is
the computer science that i'm trying to
do
and um and it can be frustrating because
i'm definitely trying to to keep an open
mind and
by doing so again as i do politically
it's not that i'm not political and i'm
some you know milk white
you know kind of bland flavorless person
i
i achieve neutrality by wild excursions
to the left and the right you know
politically from known chomsky to ben
shapiro
and from people like uh you know sir
roger penrose and paul steinhardt
on the left i don't know uh uh
scientifically
you know two people like john preskill
and
frank wilczyk and and and others on the
other side
that are you know conventional kind of
scientific thinkers that that
in in terms of the narrative that
dominates cosmology now
you know kamran vapha and the one thing
that inflation took place that string
theory is
is a you know valid paradigm to approach
the fundamental unification of forces so
i achieve neutrality but i never give
either side
you know a free pass and i criticize
both of them or both of them
legitimately i believe
um for some of the blind spots that they
may have and and i think that's what
makes it unique you have to
you take a stand you're not just like
this bland you know kind of tell me why
you're so great and why you're so
brilliant
uh that's not the way i want to conduct
my my particular interviews or conduct
my scientific research
and i think you know galileo felt that
again i'm comparing myself 100 to
galilee
uh but yeah but no well i think your
books have incredible similarities
in the way that you break down the human
flaws in doing this
science on the big stage so i i think
that that's a fair comparison in many
ways
thank you yeah i i mean i feel like you
know i mean it's
it's i don't i don't feel like i
approach what what he
had has done but i do want to point out
that you know some of the greatness of
galileo
again stems from his ultimate humanity
and his knowledge of human nature
but again there he had huge blind spots
as well
you know he had he had this uh you know
this concept
that uh you know that he could say
whatever he wanted to
uh because of you know something that
the pope said in passing before he was
pope
and and that he could put the words of
the catholic church in the mouth of a
simpleton
that everybody knew he was talking about
um you know from those perspectives i
think
you know he was he was very uh very
naive
maybe intentionally so and and nowadays
i think we have we have people like that
as well but you know what's so what was
so delightful for me
is that he would uh he would look at
questions that we wrestle with to this
day you know for example
we think about um we think about uh the
what's known in psychology as like
denial of death
so i found this amazing passage that
really spoke to me and he goes i found
the deeper i go considering the vanities
of popular reasoning the lighter and
more foolish i find them
this is in the dialogue this is a book
about like the orbit of the earth the
the origin of the earth tides you're
like what the heck
he's talking about death and how people
are naive
but greater stupidity can be imagined
than by calling jewels silver
and gold precious and earth and soil
base
people who do this ought to remember
that if there were as great a scarcity
of
soil as of jewels or precious metals
there would not be a prince
who would not spend a bushel of diamonds
and rubies
and a cart load of gold just to have
enough
to of earth and soil to plant a jasmine
in a little pot or to sow an orange seed
and watch it sprout grow and produce
handsome leaves fragrant flowers and
fine fruit
this is not like you know some boring
dry bland
scientists this is a man right of
erudition a renaissance man in the
truest sense
and i aspire as i say i can't write as
beautiful as him
but uh but he another another passage if
you'll indulge me brendan he's
yeah he presages what we now call the
dunning-kruger effect
which as you know is is something like
the less you know of something the more
you think you're an expert
of course and he says we all learned
that the hard way in in this field
yeah he goes like this he says the vain
presumption of understanding
everything can have no basis other than
never understanding anything for anyone
who had experienced just once
the perfect understanding of one single
thing
and had truly tasted how knowledge is
accomplished
he would recognize that of the infinity
of other truths
he knows nothing and this is just a
mesmerizing account of things that took
hundreds of years for social scientists
to come up with
but um the last thing i'll say is
towards the end he says just as an
illustration of how
amazing a writer he was he said i do not
presume
to be able to adduce all the proper and
sufficient causes
of those effects which are new to me and
which consequently i have had no chance
to think about
what i'm about to say i propose merely
as a key
to open portals to a road never before
trodden by anyone
in a firm hope that mine's more acute
than mine will broaden this road and
penetrate
further along it than i have done and my
first revealing of it
so this is this is like you can see
there's a little bit of sarcasm there's
a little bit of
hubris there's a little bit of of kind
of ego and then there's a little bit of
humility and
how amazing is that you know to have
this book that speaks to me across
the millennia almost half a millennia uh
it's just
it's just there's no question it's my
favorite book of science including my
own book
yeah and it speaks you know um i don't
want to hold you too long brian
did you have another 20 minutes i could
go okay
yeah so um one of the incredible things
about the fact that it speaks to you
across millennia is
that it represents a scientific method
and the great thing about the scientific
method and the reason it shouldn't be
trampled upon by politicians
or by scientists or by people with
agendas of any form
is that as long as the scientific
remains the iterative
holy process that it is it will continue
to inspire people millennia from now
um and it is not to be toiled with uh it
is a it is
because at the end of the day the
scientific method
is as much human nature
as uh as as being hungry i mean
the this the scientific method was how
we found food the scientific method was
how we found clean water
the scientific method was how we found
clothes yeah and the scientists
come to decision about uh consensus
about climate change i mean
yes and vaccines being safe etc but my
problem is that
the more you tell people that you know
um that
you know things are subjective that you
can choose you can do everything you
want and of course we can choose but you
can't
say you know scientifically that i don't
believe
a virus is causing this particular
malady that's afflicting whose name we
cannot mention
we can't say that it's a ghost it's a
spirit um but the same token is you know
the people that will say
and one day they'll say don't wear masks
uh and they do it for completely
legitimate reasons i mean they did the
same thing with second-hand smoke
uh when when you were a little baby
probably uh you don't remember this but
they say secondhand smoke kills
you know 50 000 people a year they just
ended up making it up
in a certain sense because they felt
that the outcome
was more important that we got people to
stop smoking and nowadays you get
way more uh you know videos and and
commercials at least in california i
don't remember in new york where i grew
up but
about the evils of smoking and nothing
absolutely nothing about the evils of
drinking i'm not gonna advocate
people should go out and smoke six packs
a day like my friend and mentor jim
simon does for the last 60 years
but nevertheless i will say that from
the perspective of you know
what is scientifically true how many
people like beat up their
wives and their kids you know after
having a pack of cigarettes versus a
six-pack i mean there's no
so when people say that or here's here's
another one of my favorite ones you know
i'm a pilot
um so what's the first thing you do when
you get on a plane um
on an airliner they say shut off your
phone put it in airline mode right
so do you think that um that first of
all do you think everybody complies with
that
brennan that role oh absolutely i think
i'm guilty of not doing it sometimes so
and and
and how many plane crashes have you
survived so far
i've survived three actually you've been
in three plane crashes commercials
i'm kidding of course yes okay so yeah
so none right so so the odds and i'll
tell you as a pilot
you know that the the the possibility
the probability the odds of getting
killed in such a plane crash
uh caused by someone's inherent use of a
cell phone not in airplane mode
are basically microscopic infinite yeah
and i'm not giving advice you know
whatever i always comply with myself and
on my own airplanes when i do fly my own
planes on those occasions however um the
fact
is that there's a reason they do it has
nothing to do with the scientific cause
and effect of crashing planes and that's
because
it's a way of establishing sort of
authority of the
commander of the of the of the plane the
pilots themselves
yeah and and the flight attendants they
need to have an authority
to tell you to sit down put on your seat
belt so that you'll listen to them when
the plane is going down
because it ingested a flock of birds on
each side of its wings
um and so for that reason they view it
as well we're going to say
something kind of scientific but it's
really mostly
theatrical and psychological so that we
will have control when we really need it
i feel like it's almost the opposite
like
the more you tell people things that
aren't true in the name of science
it may be down to a negative effect when
science is really necessary like curing
a disease
combating climate change etc etc and so
yeah i am i'm wary of saying listen to
scientists when it means obey scientists
yeah no i i couldn't agree more i i do
think that that is
i think that that does drive a lot of
science denial when you tell people
listen to the science listen to the
science listen to the science and then
you have people saying but wait a minute
the science doesn't really make
all that sense like why why are we
enforcing lockdowns for example the
ordinary person
even if lockdowns are the better option
than staying on them
even if that's true you need to have
public health officials
and and scientists at the ready willing
to
answer the questions that ordinary
citizens have
truthfully these are not conspiracy
theorists my
my mom asking me why she's not allowed
to go to work is not a conspiracy theory
she's a concerned citizen and our job as
scientists
is to communicate the reasons for the
for for her not to be concerned or the
risk
that you're taking or that sort of thing
you know i was a
the other day i had discovered this
great thing that's on the
weather.gov and you don't get snow where
you live but
i get tons of snow around actually in
the eastern part of san diego we get a
lot of snow
oh do you really have mountains that are
you know seven eight thousand feet high
yeah
yeah yeah but not as much as last year's
property yeah not san diego
not rochester um yeah so we get a ton of
snow and i found this great
model on weather.gov where you can click
through the different amounts and it
will tell you the percentage
chance of you getting that amount of
snow in other words out of all the
models we run
sixty percent of the models indicate you
will get more than four inches
and i was saying to my wife i don't know
why we don't communicate this to people
on meteorological channels because this
is a great way for my brain to picture
it's like
okay so out of 100 models that were run
60 of them gave us more than
four inches of snow 40 of them did not
so then
i my scientific mind works really well
in that it's like oh okay that makes a
lot of sense so
you know but she you know she kind of
illuminated me maybe this is my
confirmation bias
that ordinary people are just not taught
to think like that like [ __ ] that does
not illuminate for her anything else she
would rather the weather channel just
give her a number
and so um it is a tough
job nonetheless my point is to
communicate accurate signs to people
the complexities that don't get
communicated end up leading to doubt
you see it in meteorology and you see it
in
climate and you see it in diseases you
see it everywhere
but i think it is a net negative to
openly communicate lies or deception
because you think it is for the greater
good it is never for the greater good
i i believe it is never for the greater
i agree i think it comes back to
scientists as well when they're using
political pawns you know i make the
point in this upcoming prager university
video that yeah if you
if you uh every four years we get told
why by 70 nobel laureates 50 nobel
laureates whatever which one of the
democrats we should vote for it's never
been a republican my whole life
um and you know i'm wondering is that
because you know republicans were so
you know so anti-scientific i mean
you're kind of mentioning well they're
not really the parties
you know i i don't know if that's
actually true but but let's just say
it's it's true
so we get told who we should vote for by
all these nobel laureates or they'll
sign a petition you know we should be in
the paris accords and we should be in
the iran treaty
or whatever they get political and we're
supposed to listen to them because
of what is called the halo effect which
is another form of anti-scientific bias
you know einstein was brilliant he was
um
you know he came up with a theory of
relativity in two different forms
he understood the photoelectric effect
brownie in motion et cetera et cetera
you know all this
he also didn't believe in the
uncertainty principle basically
didn't believe in in what's called
action at a distance he didn't believe
the universe was expanding
and yet despite all this he was asked to
be the second
president of the state of israel he was
asked to testify about certain
you know the morality of using the
atomic bomb et cetera et cetera
um and and i point out again like i did
with fritz haber you know fritz knew a
lot about the chemical structure of
of nitrogen fixation he didn't know
about uh
you know the moral implications and he
died after uh
his his uh his wife and i believe two of
his kids committed suicide some say
because of the guilt they harbored from
their relationship with their father and
or husband
and his uh you know his insistence that
it was actually
okay to use chemical weapons even though
germany had signed a treaty
of owing to it so uh and my point is
look at like william shockley
like guy was brilliant he co-invented
the the uh the transistor he won the
nobel prize
uh he believed that african americans
are inferior to whites
explicitly said it and they should be
encouraged using economic
means to become biologically sterilized
i mean can you imagine a more
horrific thing to uh to say about
another human being which i believe is
created
in the image of god or whatever has
infinite worth worth beyond any
anything else any human being i don't
care what your color
race creed orientation identification
whatever okay
so should we listen to him he's a
scientist uh in fact he was so
uh so committed to this idea that he was
uh he was the only known contributor
depositor
in what was called the nobel prize sperm
bank uh it was called the genius factory
it was actually in northern san diego
county
where i am now he actually confirmed
that he did because he wanted his genes
to proliferate
so as to accrue to the benefit of all
mankind as alfred
put in his will so i think let's be very
careful nowadays james watson
openly says things about women that are
horrific
sexist disgusting uh some say he does
that just to get attention
and because he knows he's not cancelable
but yet we never retract these nobel
prizes we never take away
this esteem the highest esteem as i
write the goldenest the most shiny
of all golden calves in in society is
the nobel prize
so much so that they get asked to opine
on who you should vote for
so now let me ask you you know if if
you're gonna outsource
your political decisions to these
scientists sometimes you're going to get
people that tell you you have to listen
to the shockleys and the
and the habers and the watsons of the
world and
i think that's inherently dangerous and
i think it's a sign of cowardice by
politicians
to say we're gonna just do what the
scientists tell us to do no i didn't
elect
uh fauci he's not my he's not the
president i'm gonna
you shouldn't be take advice from him
and then we
you should wait uh uh president biden
you're my president
uh i re-elected you and and the point is
you're not out
you're not allowed to outsource it this
decision so that you could later say
well we did what science told no you
have to make judgments you have to make
wisdom-based judgments that's why we
elected you don't outsource it to
unelected people
or else you could get rule by you know
the scientists just as
a galileo and uh and others experienced
it's it's a very perilous pursuit
yeah no i i i agree with you a million
percent and you know i'll
i'll say you know to go back to the
weather analogy i'll just i'll
we can kind of end with this concept if
the
if um you know the weather channel told
you
that we were going to get 18 inches of
snow every time it snowed because they
didn't want you out getting in a car
crash
even though we were only gonna get two
inches of snow i think after a single
month you would not trust them anymore
and that is what we don't want to happen
with the scientific endeavor in general
when i saw publications like nature
publications like scientific american
endorsing joe biden as president i
was livid with this enterprise that i am
a part of
because this science does not endorse
anyone
science is not an endorsable thing or
something that can be
uh endorse or endorse somebody else
science yes it is not political and in
making it political
you do what every other institution in
this country has
done which is overly politicize every
decision
and make everyone on the other side
distrust you so i fear
i'm not hopeful at all i think science
is going to
reach and i've said this vocally over
the past few months i think science is
going to reach an epitome
of distrust in the coming years during
the biden administration and i and i
think
that that's not going to be joe biden's
fault it's not going to be fouchy's
fault
it's it's going to be the way that
average americans blame science when bad
decisions are made
when pipelines are canceled and people
lose their jobs people are going to say
that was a scientific decision those
scientists must be stupid
and distrust the entire endeavor and i
will like to walk back something i said
i don't think that in general the right
is anti-science i don't mean to say that
um i think the right
is anti-many things i don't think
they're anti-science i don't think
they're overly sexist i don't think
they're racist i don't think they're any
of those things
um i think that they look at sort of
scientific advancement
in a much more calculated nuanced way
than maybe people in the left do
i think that they say well let's use a
pipeline
you know something they might favor
instead of driving stuff by train
because guess what we're not going to
stop using gas tomorrow
oil's not going away and so they're more
dangerous right
yes so i think that they're uh i don't
mean to say they're anti-science and i
wish i wouldn't have said that but i'll
walk that
back now that's fine so we'll retract
that yeah i i agree i mean i think that
there's no this shouldn't be like
science is political in fact my joke
used to be
you know i like being an astronomer
because no one looks up and says oh i
hate that republican asteroid
and i love that uh democratic comment
you know it doesn't make any sense
uh it should be a political and in fact
you know for the benefit of some you
know we always say
that um religion should be kept out of
uh education i believe that
even though i might educate my children
according to my my
jewish faith on the other hand um we
never say you know
we say it's good for religion uh for us
to have a secular government i could not
agree
more strongly i think it's the best form
of government is to have non-uh
you know have a secular government
however why isn't that not also equally
good for science
and the arts to have it be apolitical
why do we have
you know politicians you know toilets
that are in in the art world
you know that are called america that
you relieve yourself on for a fee you
know this is considered high art
um you know why why is art politicized
why is science politicized
it's bad for art it's bad for science
just in the same way that education and
government
are bad when they incorporate religion
and gods and so forth
so i do think that you know we should
have separation of scientists and state
you know not that that we shouldn't have
i'm all for actually one of my
uh you know the the the widow of my
advisor in graduate school francis
arnold
um she uh was was married to um to
andrew lang who is
my advisor committed suicide as i
mentioned in my book very tragic event
um
and not you know the least of whom was
effective as me but but his family his
children etc
and the whole world but um but she's now
serving in the
office of of scientific advisors it may
be true that biden is much more open to
scientific advice
i i hope that you're wrong
uh that it will be you know viewed as as
uh ushering in a new dark age so to
speak where people distrust science
um but i can't really argue at this
moment when people are
really thinking that science is this
magical capability to know the answers
and the problem is that scientists are
cultivating that image
you know when i hear something like oh
professor keating i'm no einstein
you know i'm not smart some kid or like
i'll never be like that
you know i had jim gates on who's the
ford foundation professor at brown
university a friend of mine father of
super symmetry theory uh and uh and he
said einstein wasn't always einstein you
know it's like
we do science a disservice when we say
oh it's only capable to be done by these
very specialized people
with specialized equipment that have
access to
specialized knowledge that you may not
have access to
you know mrs drachler and you know
whatever uh and so i think it's i think
it's uh
it does science a disservice it excludes
other minds
you know from around the world who might
not feel like they can do this because
oh look at these scientists they're
never wrong
they always get things right especially
when they predict about the future
nothing as we know as professional
scientists could be further from the
truth i wonder brandon if you have time
to go into the impossible with me my
signature yes i do
three and yes yeah before we jump into
the impossible
one final comment that i think can
really leave this this
state of the universe on a great show or
on a great note which is that
the fact that the left is willing to
take ownership of science
and the fact that the right is willing
to try to fight that
movement implies that both political
sides really do revere science and hold
it to a high regard
which is yeah if we want to find a
diamond in the rough
that's the diamond defined that science
is is but they should listen to each
other it shouldn't be like you know when
i won the i won this presidential award
for young scientists
and i received it from george w bush and
i remember a lot of my friends were like
you're going to talk to that war
criminal
he's scum he's scumbag right far right
and they were just going off and
defending me the platforming whatever
back then
yeah all right what do you do back then
you just don't talk to someone anymore
i was just like all right no i don't i
take one i'm hurting for people to talk
to that are really brilliant people
and that i enjoy talking remember my my
first keatings filter
keating's razor is am i gonna have fun
with this
particular chunk of 30 minutes to 90
minutes whatever
um so just cut them off sorry you lose
yeah
i don't really care and that goes for
anybody you know if if dome chomsky's
not going to come on the show or if you
know chunky eager or some guy
they're not going to all right good you
lost town talking to to
and having a good conversation uh that
is about the best of us you know about
the best of the human mind
is when we explore its outermost
boundaries
but um but you know and then it was just
funny to me to then see
you know 15 years later my friend saying
oh
trump why can't he be more like george
bush like the same people who are like
canceling me back then oh like george
but you know he goes to baseball games
with ellen degeneres and like
look at look at her uh michelle obama
hugging him yeah it really
was hilarious to see because i recognize
that too i i remember george bush being
this
hated vilified character and now he's
looked back upon as this like i guess
with the benefit of of uh cpt uh and
variance so
what do you what can you predict a
hundred percent to be the case
just based on this example that we just
gave and and you can add in mitt romney
remember like
you know all the awful things he was
going to do and
but now he's like a hero of the
democratic party as far as republicans
are concerned
so what can we now say i think
i i this is a tough this is a bold
prediction okay but i think can we say
that donald trump will be revered in a
few years
exactly yes in like 10 10 years everyone
will look back on this
everyone screaming at us
he's of course he's worse than hitler as
spike lee just called him recently you
know
he's like okay all right well we'll see
what happens you know good luck yeah
all right let's go into the impossible
because i gotta get back to the lab and
meet with my grad students i'm having so
much fun with you
uh let's do i wanna make sure that we
get to these final questions here on the
into the impossible podcast
so as you know from reading the book
alfred nobel endowed this golden
medallion
and he said it must go to the person the
person single person
uh we're not going to get into that as i
discussed in the book but um
who had the greatest benefit
to mankind through his basically his he
meant back then but his or her nowadays
of course
luckily so we have many women winning it
although only two of which are
whom are alive today uh in physics at
least but anyway getting back to it
he said that their discoveries or
inventions must benefit all of mankind
and now they change that to humankind
thankfully
but i want to ask you that's what's
known as an ethical will
when you give not only monetary goods
and services but you give away ethical
wisdom
to future generations and i want to ask
you as a as a young person when you
reach the biblical age of 120 and spring
forth this mortal coil
what wisdom what one piece of wisdom
would you most want to leave for the
future
what one piece of wisdom would i i i
think
i it's so cliche but it's real like
okay i had duncan lorem run on my show
once and he
had used this phrase youth is wasted on
the young
and i constantly go back to this phrase
in my mind this is a great phrase and
to really probe it and i think that as
as you get old
you really start at older you really
start to pursue the things in life that
you find most important and you begin
to sort of get out of the shell that you
trapped yourself in which we talked
about the beginning of our recording
together
which is that i kind of put up these
barriers in my own world of growth in
the podcast right
we are ta i am a do have a top 10
astronomy physics show on the on the
planet
but i could have so much more if i could
break down those barriers and just be
who i want to be or who i think i am so
i think that's the piece of wisdom i
would
i would sort of leave behind in
everything and science
in life in all of it is that you have to
pursue
you you have to fundamentally understand
who you
are and i think we all have a great
barometer for that we all have a great
barometer for what we like to do
what we like to be you know barring any
like mental illness or depressive states
which we we all
suffer from we do all have great
barometers for who we
should be and oftentimes we don't have
the will or the ability or the the um
sort of confidence in ourselves to
pursue who we should be being
and so that would be the piece of wisdom
i would be leave behind is if you're a
scientist
pursue the science you want to pursue
with all of your might pursue it pursue
it pursue it if you have an idea
chase it in life and entertain no matter
what it is
identify the things that that get you up
in the morning and
tackle them like tackle them tackle them
as if nothing else
matters on the planet so i guess that's
yeah that's the wisdom i'd leave
awesome well as you know i'm the
co-associate director
associate co-director i always forget my
title of the arthur c clarke center for
human imagination
at the university of california san
diego i'm the proprietor of the into the
impossible podcast so please tune into
that
if you're listening on brendan's channel
and then please tune in to uh
state of the universe on itunes as well
we are always duking it out for
top 10 status in this domain and as i
said i've learned so much
and i've been inspired by the passion
the intense relentless curiosity of
mind that brandon exhibits and
exhilarates
okay question number two what piece of
knowledge would you put on your monolith
if you've seen the movie 2001 a space
odyssey these monoliths feature
prominently
therein these are time capsules left by
an ancient
alien civilization to serve as a warning
as a
talisman or perhaps just as a time
capsule for future generations
and it's not unlike richard feynman uh
the so-called cataclysm
question which went as follows if in
some
sign in some cataclysm all of scientific
knowledge were to be destroyed
and only one sentence passed on to the
next generation of creatures
what statement would convey the most
information in a single sentence
and then he gives his uh his answer to
that but i'm not he's not on the podcast
right
now i'm trying to get him on the podcast
via gpt3
synthesized synthetic feynman a einman
but we'll see if that ever happens but
anyway brandon what is your
kind of statement or knowledge or phrase
that you'd put on a
billion-year-lasting time capsule
that is an excellent excellent question
and i don't know
hmm what phrase would i put on a time
capsule
if i was sending it off see this kind of
makes me just like kind of want to
copyright
or or rather plagiarize carl sagan's uh
voyager decisions um that's fine i
actually had his widow
and durian on the show and she said yeah
i did that on the golden disc
yeah yeah so um that's fine
but i don't know if you're an academic
you're supposed to plagiarize
maybe for the sake of yeah how about it
maybe for the sake of the uh
the episode we just did i i think
um things are not as you perceive them
to be
maybe that would be an excellent way to
uh
to inspire the future generation to come
up with their own science and
and here's why i wouldn't want to put
anything too scientific
because if we could imagine that the
next civilization is not quite like us
there's no guarantee that they come up
with the same science we did
there's no guarantee they come up with
general relativity it's possible
they come up with an equally valid
theory of gravity that is not general
relativity
because general relativity is likely not
the final tombst the final domino at the
end of the
gravity well if you will um there's more
to be found
there's always more to be found and the
question is is that
the only mathematical description you
can come up with to describe
space time as we know it the answer
might be no so i think
um for the sake of this fake simulation
that we're talking about
uh i think i would warn them about
confirmation bias and i would let them
run amok
and allow them to pursue the science
that that they can find for themselves
very good
that is excellent what would you what
what would you do brian i i don't i know
this is a questions for me but
did you have an answer for that one oh
for that one uh
yes so i would put more of a moral uh or
ethical
implication on on such an object but uh
but specifically
uh for scientific knowledge i would say
that the you know the most
scientific information that could be
contained
would be uh something like the the
structures
of galaxies stars planets and organisms
are predicated on the existence of atoms
which were themselves
forged in either fiery supernova
cauldrons or within the first three
minutes of cosmic existence
and what came before that may forever
be firewalled off from our vision and
our notion
and and so forth but in the second
sentence because i can do it because of
my show
at least this section is as i would say
that we should never let our curiosity
really be exceeded or fail to live up to
what our imagination is capable of uh
the last question and the thrilling
three
questions that we ask all of our
esteemed guests and who honor us by our
present their presence
uh is going backwards in time so we went
a billion years in the future the time
capsule
you just answered we went into the
future when you're 120. now i want to go
backwards to add
advice to your former self to a how old
are you now
i am 25 25 wow
half my age that's phenomenal um i want
to ask you i normally say
what advice would you give to a 30 year
old that's not going to work
but i want to ask you what advice would
you give to a 20 year old
brandon dracula that is in enable you
to do what the title of this podcast my
podcast at least
is which is the into the impossible
podcast which derives from arthur c
clarke's third law which is the only way
of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them
into the impossible name of this podcast
let gonna ask you what would you advise
your former self maybe a 15 let's go
let's go 12 and a half
let's go half your age what would you
advise a young brendan to
do in order to develop the courage as
you have to go
into the impossible
if i was 15 or if i was advising my
fifth well first i'd tell
myself to get off the opioids which i
wouldn't have done for another year or
two
but um i would tell myself that and then
uh
is that real or beyond being honest yeah
yeah yeah
i had yeah so i have well this is your
patreon so i talk about on the show from
time to time
i was a drug addict from a very young
age i started doing drugs when i was 12
and i didn't get truly clean until i was
16 or 17. so um so
what i would do is tell my 15 year old
self
pursue science because i did not start
the journey to become an astrophysicist
until i was 18 a senior in high school
at 18 because i had failed
some high school grades because i just
didn't go i didn't care about school i
was too busy wrapped up in
my life of nefarious drug doing that i
knew but um i didn't know that was
because
of an addiction issue yes
so um what was the thing that that that
kind of got you out of it was it a
12-step program was it like
friends and family how did you overcome
i mean that's like
one of the that's i say to my wife all
the time we're blessed to have children
and i say to her all the time i'm like
the one thing i
i pray to the extent i believe prayer
can actually do anything
but the one thing i do is that they will
be free from addictions of all kinds it
could be
social media addiction it could be you
know pornography whatever
food i've had tremendous challenge with
with food i've gained and lost 50 pounds
many times in my life and i'm currently
trying to lose it
um i suffer from that you know kind of
addiction now we don't in society
typically think of it as
in the same kind of classes you know as
some awful thing and i'm not saying that
drug addiction or substance abuse is but
i do pray for that my wife and i agree
on that um
and it's the one thing that makes your
child lose his or her free will
i believe and therefore not be your
child anymore and and i've had
conversations with with you know with
the most esteemed you know theologians
and
and secularists and i think all agree
but i'm curious
brent how did you overcome it what was
the was there i mean
obviously it's not a hack and you know
do these crazy simple tricks and there's
a loophole and you'll get no how did you
overcome it that's a that's a tremendous
accomplishment i think it was
exact something you had mentioned which
is that you lose your free will
i think i started to realize that i
think i started to realize i'm losing my
fri i think i started i looked around me
and i
i saw all these people who were in the
same position as me and i saw that
this small coal region town with in
pennsylvania with nothing to offer
anyone
um is a proverbial black hole and
the only way to get out of the black
hole is to
climb against the tide very hard and a
ton of credit to my wife my now wife who
was
an addict with me at the time and we
just decided that you know we don't want
to live
well two things i don't want to put my
kids in a situation that i was in
yeah i which is why i have not had kids
yet
with my wife of many years now um
i don't want to put them in a situation
where they have to worry about any of
that stuff
and so uh i think it was just like
that situation as i just realized i need
to
i i'm on an amazing planet in an amazing
uni i was always interested in astronomy
i would get high and stare at the stars
you know and my opioid riddled uh
life and um and i just realized that
this isn't where free will exists
you know and i i need to pursue
something that i'm
i'm passionate about and i went back to
school in the 10th grade
and after i hadn't really been in an
institution
for two years i mean i was there but i
was wasn't there
uh i was expelled i was you know
all the stuff so um go back to school
get the education go to college i i'm
gonna pursue this astrophysics thing and
um you know my wife was there with me we
went to the same college together we
went
we did it all together so um i think it
was just that it's like
i wanted free will and um i think
i think maybe i was blessed with the
fact that maybe i think
more deeply about some of these
questions than other people and i don't
mean to say that
i don't mean to say that in a way that's
like derogatory towards anyone else i
don't think i'm smarter than anyone else
but
i i i did i was always
perplexed with these questions about um
and i think just people who are
predisposed to do astrophysics
are you know like we had talked about on
my show about you before
like maybe the last recording is your
interest in cosmology stems from a very
deep place
it doesn't just it's not something you
just wake up when you're 16 and want to
do
there's some underlings there's some
underlying reasons why you want to know
about the beginning of the universe
and i think that there were some
underlying reasons why i wanted to too
and i was blessed with
having that outlet and i think many
people aren't blessed with having that
outlet
i think many people are confused with
what they want to do and and uh
drugs make it easy to be in that
situation so
um i think yeah you you're kind of you
know saved by the stars in a certain
sense and it always
rankles me when people like you know sam
harris or tim ferriss or whatever kind
of
dabble in this because i think it's a
very slippery slope um you know i kind
of er on the other side and you could
say that that's child abuse or whatever
but
basically trying to connote to my kids
that it's a zero strikes policy like
you try opioids not just like i didn't
you know i tried diet coke i didn't
really care for it i liked diet no it's
not like that
uh and so it kind of make it a
four-letter word just like you're never
gonna try this
um you know and and here are the reasons
why
uh but the people say oh you can kind of
dance around it like it's true with food
and i always
use this as an excuse and you know i'm
sure uh jocko willink
uh would would uh you know kind of kick
my ass for saying but you know it's like
food you have to eat you have to eat
certain amount of food every day
and so the the issue for me is
controlling portion or what
you know kinds of macronutrient whatever
but you don't have to do
you know opioids like that's not part of
like everyday life unless you're
excruciating pain um so i i do think
it's
it is a very slippery slope i do believe
that you lose free will and people like
sam harris and and others that kind of
not glorify it because i know he's he's
definitely pulled back a lot on it
but you know as a tool you know i i do
worry about that the effects that that
might have
and you know i'm not making judgments
about you know that for
specific use and i know that you know
painkillers are life savers for many
people
so it's it's but it's not just a
question of well like
let's recreationally do it you know i
have friends who do who do
uh you know companies that have to do
with you know kind of like raves you
know these parties and stuff
most of their customers are like on
drugs while they're doing it and i'm
like well
you know this but like you're kind of
like feeding off it maybe taking
advantage of it you know how is that
morally ethically okay
and it's usually like well you know
everyone's got free will to take drugs
but i'm like not once they start taking
it
you know oftentimes you don't and if i
can get addicted to eating
you know how much more so can someone
get addicted to things that could be
permanently maybe irreversibly harmful
in some cases i i don't claim to be an
expert on this but
but i do want to point out one last
thing in relation to this that my friend
and uh you know upcoming guest and past
guest dr judson brewer at brown
university my alma mater
for grad school he's coming back on the
show he wrote a book called the craving
mind
and it's about overcoming addictions to
things uh like eating and smoking
and you know what he says is the most
potent tool for
overcoming at least those addictions i'm
not claiming it would work for opioid
addiction but i'm just curious
uh to i was curious about it and the
word is curiosity
and that the human brain released a
little bit of dopamine when it
require acquires new information or new
hypotheses and i wonder with you
that you recognize maybe you're losing a
little bit of that imagination that
creativity that
you know only a few of us you know
really get to use for a little bit of
our time as scientists
until we uh we get older and no longer
can process the same way we can but i
wonder if the curiosity
that is intrinsic to you is that feature
of you that allows you to break out and
as i say go into the impossible
yeah yeah it it might very well be and i
like the conf the intel it's funny
because
everything in my life prepared me for
the life i live now
including the opioids including the
addictions including the drugs of all
forms
because when you would be around these
people that and you'd be doing
very psychedelics you'd be smoking weed
you'd be doing
uh you know uh pills you whatever you're
doing
the conversations that you get in are
actually incredibly deep
most addicts know that they have a
problem most addicts know that they're
addicted
and most addicts are incredibly curious
people i just think people are actually
in general and
you spend your time with addicts you'll
find that um and so you have these
incredibly incredibly deep
curious conversations and
um i don't know why so my point is i
don't know why
it would have propelled me out of the
situation and not others and
and um i'm not doubting that that's what
did it i think that's exactly what did
it
but i'm just curious why it doesn't do
it for more people yeah um no
and then i will i will say if i could uh
give my older self advice and by proxy
give you advice
for your your children i would say that
the way you talked about food
where you need food to survive i think
many addicts
look at heroin that same way where they
say
they do need the heroin to survive
because they're not filling their
stomach they're filling a void that
exists
in their life and if you don't instill
that void into your children
i'd think you won't have a problem with
them being hungry for heroin or
any [ __ ] vice for that matter the
obviously
the incredible hard aspect of that
exact sentence is how do you not instill
pain in your children that is an answer
a question i do not have the answer to
brian but i'm convinced that
you have a much better answer than i and
i'm sure you're doing a great job
at doing just that well i always joke
with my wife you know and like the kids
are acting up or sometimes
get the instruction manual you know
because i'm like so uh whatever left
brain i always forget what brand yes but
anyway
but the point is yeah and doing that and
um
really you know it's like i feel like
innocence is really
you know underappreciated it's it's it's
perhaps the greatest
uh most perishable of all resources you
know people say you know time you can
never
get back time yeah you can waste a lot
of time like you know
you and i are watching our share of cat
videos please um but
uh but innocence is is really not only
perishable in time you know
from from a young age to the age you
know like you were telling me 12 years
old
i think you lost your innocence in a
certain sense and and
that's much more perishable because it's
time bound and it's kind of wrapped up
in your
in your soul in your in your spirit and
it is
we believe as as jews that every person
has this opportunity
for for doing teshuva which is you know
loosely translated as repentance
but it's really like being reborn and i
don't mean like
like praise jesus that's fine you know
people do that born again
but you were born again and it's thanks
to science so i think
you know that is a sort of you know we
have to be careful because science is
not a religion
it's a substitute religion talk about
nobleism in my book
uh but the fact is that this curiosity
that you have
was probably your your salvation and
your redemption and i
i do want to salute you i always knew i
had a tremendous amount of respect from
you for you
i think you're doing an amazing job i i
you know i envy you
in a certain sense because you're
starting so young you're so bright so
talented
and and you have such a good foundation
head on your shoulders
don't ever lose that courage that you
have uh don't ever lose that kind of
intensity and fearlessness to take on
issues even if they're not popular
because those are the people that make
all the difference so brenda i want to
thank you so much for going into the
impossible at the end of your podcast
state of the universe everyone tune in
to that and here's
brendan's information his twitter handle
the link to the podcast subscribe
support him
on all those different channels brendan
have a wonderful day and if you want to
sign off from your end i'll sign off
from my end
and uh and i can't wait to get together
with you again
sounds good brian yeah hopefully next
time it's in person
that would be nice i miss rochester i
don't know if i missed it in january
february but i do miss new
didn't miss it in the uh any time after
you know kind of
yeah may and and i might be 20 in the
near future and i'll certainly swing by
and see you in russia i will say and
i will do that in april 2024 the total
solar eclipse will be over rochester so
oh that's right
okay so you're going to jack up the real
estate on the airbnb you said you'd love
it
all right be well have a great weekend
and keep doing what you're doing
yeah same to you brian we'll we'll talk
bye